see girls is like not someone to like
sort of build things like as on the same
team they were almost the enemy even if
we were doing good together I was always
like wary of the levels whereas recently
I've taken a big step back from that
therapy as you said meditation
journaling reading books on dating
reading books on attachment Styles and I
think the childhood stuff is like very
very important here but it's like I've
actually started to love being around
women and love having that feminine
energy around me and it's like the
moment that you kind of like level
things up with us it's such like a
beautiful experience that I was always
ignorant to because I was entirely
focused on like the number clothes and
the lay clothes pickup was started by
Asperger and autistic guys that had no
idea how to communicate to women so the
fact that there's a lot of digital
market value Peaks graphs hectograms and
scores out of 10. it doesn't surprise me
because that's what a lot of the people
that began this movement thinking and
they're saying the entire pick apart
this community sees any woman's gain as
a man's loss and any man's gain is a
woman's loss that's the mentality that
pickup went into it with and I think
that you still see that now